what's up guys how's it going welcome to
ask ij the show where you guys ask me
questions and we answer them and today
my sister jenna is here hello how's it
going good this i'm here because it's my
room it is yeah we did a room we are
going to answer some questions for you
today and there's this one girl where is
she sarah she seriously has been
spamming us because she wants to know
our thoughts on the miley cyrus
performance of the vmas did you actually
did you watch i was on a plane but i
watched it as soon as i got home on
youtube and i thought
hmm
honestly i've not even seen it if you've
seen pictures you've basically seen it
let's just do it like really
i don't really i don't really care what
miley cyrus does it doesn't really
affect my life so no okay let's see what
is this okay let's look at this this is
wow
this is some miley cyrus memes it says
22 things that miley cyrus looked like
at the vmas crum little monsters i did
love that show
oh my god the jim carrey one's my
favorite yeah that is pretty much
exactly this is my favorite a back end
of a turkey oh her tongue is the only
thing that bothers me like just keep it
in your mouth okay charge our banks okay
let's go okay oh my god all right oh my
god
we get it i get it
look i'm still going
okay
what's our opinion on beyonce oh i like
her i haven't heard much about her
lately yeah i think she's busy with she
have a kid one kid two kids three kids
one kid but jay-z has a son too i think
oh
okay what's your go-to drink at
starbucks
biscuits refreshing i do like that i
like the
valencia orange oh guess what's back
poppy it's my lettuce
next question do you ever work out with
all the crap you eat
i try
i get really good i'll be like on a kick
of a month like being real healthy
running working out and then i go and
eat a bunch of cake and do nothing and
sit on my butt
true what is your high score in dots
hold on let me look on menu multiplayer
scores trophies
i don't know i'll get back to you so
these are my high scores because i
couldn't figure out how to see them will
you be getting the new gta or the new
saints row four we've already been
playing sansa for my gaming channel what
do you think i love it you can just jump
so high
so fun it was your chain it was like 90
a jump chain i don't know it was
ridiculous i can't wait for the gt
online because it's pretty much all i'm
ever gonna do i think
so you're bored until i play call of
duty until it comes out in november um
next question is
have i read the book divergent no have
you no let me tell you what i'll read
you know why because
i have the books be read to me i've been
talking about the ij book club on ij
likes because audible gave me a little
link for you guys it's audible.com
ijustine where you guys can get a 30 day
free trial and a free book free you're
choosing what book did you get i got uh
bossy pants by tina fey
i have no clue what it's about but i
like tina fey and i thought it would be
funny i love her she's amazing i got the
fault in our stars by john green and
it's so funny because i actually have
the autographed john green book that he
sent me and i'm like i'm sorry john i
feel like you shouldn't like open that
or touch it you should save that i did
like that's special john and hank are
like two of my favorite things they're
so nice ever great human being award
goes to john and hank
i don't have anything
do they want candy do we want can't you
guys some deodorant
let me know what free book you guys get
at audible.com i'll put links in
description because i know you guys
don't like to type so you can click
anyway next question are you a fan of
the carrot
yes yes yes yes i'm such a big fan hold
on she keeps telling me just follow this
carrot twitter account i'm like i don't
i don't i don't like i don't want to
obsess so francesca told me about this
it's real carrot facts on twitter and
these are the tweets so for example one
says have a headache eating a carrot can
help if you take an advil after it like
it's funny but like it's a carrot
twitter account miley cyrus vma
performance make my carrot stand up
oh here's another one if you paint a
pencil orange and you pretend it a
carrot but after that there is not much
you can do
it's like poor english try eating a
carrot if you are depressed you won't
feel better but at least you'll have a
taste of carrot in your mouth
i just like don't get it next question
did you see southwest airlines freaking
tweeted me a question this is the best
thing ever what's your favorite thing to
do to pass the time while flying sleep
yeah wi-fi then i can do all the things
pretty much every southwest flight i've
been on has had wi-fi the best part is
whenever you have like late flights
because then everybody's sleeping and
nobody's on the wi-fi so you can use all
bandwidth i actually think i uploaded a
video one time me too from the bathroom
oh well
i was not in the bathroom
i was just sitting in my seats
okay next question um one of the most
random and craziest thing that we've
ever done in public together
how about you guys let us know because
you've probably seen the videos and you
have a better memory yeah we are not
good at anything i don't remember um do
you and your sisters have a lot of
fights arguments no i think we're too
sleepy to fight yeah like you do get
annoyed with me though
when you're late you're always late i'm
like get your stuff together woman i was
like we have to leave you have to get in
here right now we have to shoot this
video and we have to go
it was something like that girl with
maybe a couple of bad words no i'm just
kidding
well
you tried taking care of this i just
can't do it
where do you see yourself in 10 years
jen holy crap
i don't even know where i see myself in
10 minutes so why do because we have to
leave probably me yelling at you hurry
up i don't know i like them 10 years
i'll be
34.
maybe i'll have a puppy
hamilton is the number one most
obsession
mustache
perfect mustache perfect mustache all
natural anyway all right thanks for the
questions guys that's it
i mean that is it i'll see you guys in
my next video
peace bye